and thank you all for being here I'm
super excited to have this time to talk
a little bit about some of my work on
designing for intentional technology use
so technology of course can mean a lot
of things as you all know for the
purposes of this talk we'll be talking
about the kind of user facing screen
based experiences with mask penetration
that you're all very familiar with like
mobile phones tablets computers
television and all the content that goes
along with them so these technologies
provide us with tremendous value as I'm
sure you've noticed you can video chat
with your friend on the other side of
the world you can use a tablet as a
synthetic voice if you lack the ability
to speak increasingly twitter has become
an essential mechanism for distributing
information in as part of relief efforts
in response to natural and man-made
disasters in addition to all of this
value we also spend a lot of time with
technology and so the average American
spends a little more than 10 and a half
hours a day with screen-based
experiences and checks their smartphone
about a hundred and fifty times or about
once every six minutes that you're awake
this isn't just a phenomenon that
applies to adults today American
children spend more time with screen
based technology than they do in school
and this is true kind of across
socio-economic strata so in low-income
communities in the u.s. for example
about 75% of preschoolers own their own
dedicated mobile device before they turn
four this is also true around the world
so people in places like Saudi Arabia
Indonesia and Poland South Africa for
example all share more content online
than we do here in the United States so
we are quite engaged with these
technologies we spend a lot of time with
them but these aren't always empowering
experiences so there is people often
reports in terms of what's known as
problematic internet use this is a
pattern of engaging with Internet
connected
experiences in a way that leads to
destruction Olymp Airmen of daily life
this isn't just a first world problem
and in fact as national quality of life
in a country goes down the incidence of
problematic internet use goes up so for
example a pretty recent study on college
students in Bangladesh found that about
25 percent display symptoms of pio
people say that they feel the need to
check in with technology even when they
know that it's going to make them feel
lousy when they think it's going to
compromise their productivity or even
put their physical safety at risk so at
this very moment there are six hundred
and sixty thousand people driving on a
road in the United States Wow looking at
a photo so given all of the value of the
technology adds all of the time that we
spend with it and some of these patterns
of disempowerment I'm and dysfunctional
use today managing the way we engage
with technology has become an essential
part of daily life the last thing I want
to say about this before I talk about
some of my work is that this is not an
accident this is very much a designed
phenomenon so user engagement is a
primary goal and metric for lots of tech
companies this is sometimes referred to
as the attention economy or the eyeballs
economy which just means that your
attention is valuable and generates
revenue for someone potentially through
metrics like click-through rates or ad
impressions or time spent with a
particular experience now companies have
lots of different ways of attracting and
holding your attention sometimes they do
so by providing you with an experience
that has value for you and sometimes
they do so by exploiting classic
psychological principles that they know
about you like your need to belong or
your responsiveness to variable rewards
so the goal of the studies that I'm
going to be talking about today are all
around this theme of how can we support
users in engaging with technology only
on their own terms and in ways that they
feel good about I'm going to talk about
three different projects the first is an
exploration of the kinds of limits and
boundaries that people want on their
technology use and then two different
design projects one targeting adults and
one targeting kids so this first project
on family technology rules so as the
project we called not at the dinner
table which looked at how kids and
family kids and parents set boundaries
on technology use at home and what they
want for their family so we chose to
look at the rules that families set
because rules offer this glimpse into
intentions and desired behaviors so it
tells you a little bit about what
behaviors people think are appropriate
what they want to do it also tells you a
little bit about what behaviors are
challenging what's hard to stick with so
you know parents don't say to their kids
like look you're not allowed to use your
phone to steal someone's identity
because that's not a hard challenge for
them so it gives us a little bit of
insight into what the sticky points are
so he has two questions in this project
first what rules and expectations do
children and their parents have for each
other about technology use and then what
makes these rules and expectations
easier or harder to live up to this was
a survey study we recruited 249
parent-child pairs from around the
country and these are kids between the
ages of 10 and 17 and for each family we
first asked of course the parents what
rules they had for their child's use of
Technology and this has historically
been kind of the sum total focus of
research in this space but we also kind
of wanted to take a more family centric
view where we looked at how this was
playing out for people of all ages so we
asked the kids what rules and
expectations do you have for your
parents use of technology we also asked
parents what sorts of behaviors they
thought were appropriate for themselves
and we asked kids what sorts of rules
they were expected to live up to and
then we took all of these descriptions
these open-ended descriptions of the
rules and expectations that they had and
we used content analysis to cluster that
in two different types of rules and
compare the properties of some of those
different rules so this is a rules that
we saw for kids and they clustered into
a taxonomy of twelve different
categories the area of each of these
dots represents how frequently that
particular type of rule came up for the
people in our study the most common
types of rules for what we called be
present rules these were rules about
being respectful and responsive toward
the people who are physically spending
time with so things like be present
during events and functions and
mealtimes second most common types of
rules or rules about privacy it's like I
can't give my phone number to strangers
and then we saw a number of different
types of rules things like content
restrictions no Grand Theft Auto so
rules about what kids can and can't do
with technology parent audits this is
when kids would have to like give their
social media passwords to their parents
or give them access to all their text
messages so that parents could check out
but what kids have been doing and we saw
that these categories clustered into two
overarching umbrellas that we called
activity constraints and context
constraints and these were roughly came
up roughly equivalently so about the
same number of rules in each of these
categories so activity constraints are
rules about what kids can do with
technology things like no snapchat and
these are kind of all-or-nothing rules
that either say something is okay or it
isn't second types of rules context
constraints were things like no phones
at the dinner table which didn't ban
anything outright but sort of set
contextual boundaries on when things
were and weren't okay and this
difference is interesting because we saw
that context constraints were much
harder than activity constraints
so essentially easier to just ban
something altogether than it is to set
kind of nuanced boundaries on when it is
it isn't okay to engage with so kids
said they were less likely to follow
these types of rules parents are the
they were harder to enforce and kids
told us that they required more effort
so even to get to that lower level of
compliance took more work I mentioned
the rules that we saw for parents
briefly and again these rules clustered
into a taxonomy of common themes and
again and the most common type of
expectation that parents and kids alike
had for adults in their family was be
present so kids said stuff like pay
attention put down the phone when your
child is trying to tell you something
important so the findings that came out
of this that I specifically want to
build on today first where this
important was the importance of presence
as a kind of family value so across the
spectrum across the u.s. this was the
most frequently cited rule for family
members of all ages the second is this
new problem of context so historically
rules around technology use have been
all about what we call activity
constraints here so all about what kids
can do with technology but today about
half of the rules that families are
setting are about what is ok and when
and more context specific boundaries and
then finally the piece that I want to
build on next and is this idea that
saying no is easier than saying well
sometimes and that's interesting because
we want people to be able to get the
value that they're seeking out of
technology we don't want them to have to
throw it to throw it out altogether and
so how can we support people in engaging
with experiences that they value without
bringing along all of these side effects
that they don't feel so great about so
no was easier than sometimes so the
second project kind of built directly on
that challenge this was a project that
we called my time to explore how
smartphones might help adults in
engaging in this kind of targeted
non-use that they're interested in to
help them continue using their phones in
the ways that they value and maybe cut
back on some aspects of phone use that
they don't like so much specifically
we're asking can smart phones support
users
engaging only when they feel good about
doing so I'm and to start we recruited a
panel of expert designers to come up
with as many possible design solutions
as they could these are pretty
wide-ranging but we clustered them using
affinity diagramming and they fell into
a taxonomy of eight different styles of
intervention so these same types of
approaches came up again and again so
these were things like providing users
with information so just kind of
passively surfacing information about
their usage behaviors giving them
rewards for engaging in specific types
of behaviors setting up barriers that
made it harder to engage and behaviors
they don't feel good about and so forth
then for each one of these categories we
created wireframes and storyboards with
what we call category exemplars where we
tried to really get at the essence of
that category so for example for this
information category we had this wire
frame with a widget a kind of passively
presented information about how much
time someone spent with experiences that
they want to cut back on say youth this
says you've been on Facebook for 28
minutes today something like that for
the punishment category we came up with
this design I mean you have to like come
up with some bad ideas in order to get
to the good ones I think so we came up
with this design where you would choose
a picture of something you don't want to
see like a spider or a photo of your ex
and then as you engage in this pattern
of behavior that you want to change this
image starts to appear more and more
frequently on screen I don't know
then we conducted a survey with a few
hundred people where we showed them all
of these different scenarios and we
asked them how interested they would be
in trying some of these out there were a
few that they liked and said they'd like
to give a try specifically the
information limit and mindfulness
categories there are a few they're kind
of neutral about and weren't sure if
they would try these were our
and appeal to value categories and then
there are a few that they hate it or
they thought there was no way they were
going for the spiders so we threw out
all of these and we created a compound
intervention that combined all three of
these approaches the result was an app
we called my time which lets the user
select some experiences that they want
to monitor set goals about the amount of
time they're gonna spend with those
experiences and combines all three of
these different categories so it
included this aspiration setting window
that shows up each day where you can
optionally choose to say what some of
your goals are for the day so as part of
our mindfulness approach as part of our
information approach we had this
persistent notification in the
notification shade so anytime you're
engaging them with a monitored app you
can see how you've been spending your
time and then as part of our limit of
setting approach whenever a user bumped
up against one of those boundaries that
they'd set for themselves in their
initial tracking setup this dialogue
would pop up and tell them that they had
run out of time recruited 23 Android
users to participate in a deployment
study we had them first fill out this
survey where they told us about their
current behaviors things that they feel
good about doing with their phones
things that they'd like to change and
then we collected a week of baseline
data where we just passively logged
everything that they did with their
phone without any kind of intervention
to see what they were doing and then we
did a one-week intervention deployment
where they use the buy time so we saw
that our participants chose to monitor
139 different apps we took each of the
apps that they tracked and for that
person compared those apps against their
initial survey responses to see whether
the things that they said they felt good
about using and the things they wanted
to cut back on aligned with what they
chose to monitor
and unsurprisingly most people chose to
track something that they had explicitly
said was something they wanted to use
less one thing I didn't expect was that
more than half of our participants also
chose to monitor apps that they feel
really good about using so they seem to
want to know for example how much time
they were spending with their fitness
app or managing their finances or
reading the Bible or learning a foreign
language so potentially some kind of
design opportunity there to support
people in some quantity quantified self
behaviors around monitoring things they
like doing with their phone and then
relative to their baseline use we saw
that people cut back on the amount of
time they spent with their phone by
about 33 minutes a day more
interestingly was where that reduction
came from so on the left are people's
usage data about the amount of time
people spent with the apps they feel
good about using over on the right are
the apps that people said were a waste
of their time the blue is their baseline
use and then the yellow shows what
happened the next week when they were
using my time so the amount of time
people spent with the apps they felt
good about using was unchanged and
people cut down on their waste of time
apps by about 20% which worked out to
almost an hour a day as I mentioned we
had this aspiration setting feature
where we asked people each day what they
wanted to do this was totally optional
people chose to set 57 different
aspirations across the week that they
were using my time some of these were
really topical like less Instagram usage
so something very direct directly
related to the study some of these we're
not related at all like meat cashew
cheese I guess that's what we do in
Seattle I don't know and then when these
times up dialog showed up if the user
had set an aspiration we reflected it
back to them and we did see that people
were significantly more likely to exit
the app they were using if they saw one
of their own self defined aspirations
okay so it was exciting to see that this
seemed to be effective for inducing this
short-term change and specifically that
people were able to cut back in some
areas of their use without cutting down
on phone use in general so preserving
others and that this kind of
differentiated non use aligned with the
behaviors that people said they wanted
to engage in that's good but as anyone
who's ever gone on a diet or tried to
quit smoking or designed any persuasive
technology can tell you long-term
behavior change is really hard and so
certainly understanding what happens
next is an important next step for this
project and so exploring whether this is
kind of a first step where you
transition people to other types of
supports whether this is just simply
something that doesn't work in the long
run whether this is a crutch that people
can use indefinitely whether this can
train behaviors but doesn't support
people in making changes without the
tool those are all kinds of things we'll
be exploring in the future
second this doesn't really address this
problem that came out of the first study
I talked about around context
constraints and activity constraints so
something that we're looking at now is
how we can support people in setting
kind of context specific goals so using
lightweight something to help people set
goals not just around what apps they use
or for how long but also in what context
they use them so like if you're
listening to a really great talk and you
don't want to be using your phone maybe
we can help you just and then the thing
probably that I'm most excited about
moving forward is looking beyond these
kinds of outside stand alone supports
and looking at the redesign of the
experiences themselves because across
several studies in this space I've
definitely got in the sense that people
don't really want these third-party
tools to police their usage at least not
as kind of a broad solution to this
problem
so what I am focused on right now
is exploring how we can redesign the
experiences themselves so that as people
are engaging with them it's easy for
them to set the boundaries that they
feel good about and engage the way they
want to yes advertising and engagement
makes them more money it seems like
they're always going to want to make
these things that cause you to do that
and so I'm curious whether you know is
there a way of me saying yes I want to
change this behavior and I'll put 200
dogs a year or 500 dollars a year to it
and then that money actually getting
paid to the app developers who make apps
that don't take their attention so they
can make money rather than people that
have this problem rich people wouldn't
it may be a different price for
different people
sure um so I'll talk about this a little
more at the end but you know it was a
lot harder giving this giving talks on
this topic a year ago because it just
all sort of comes back to that problem
like the incentive structure is just
driving us right toward this challenge
but it has been very exciting over the
last couple of months to see some
companies right around here starting to
do some soul-searching and rethinking
their attention economy model so like I
said I'll talk about this a little more
at the end but there are a few reasons
why I am optimistic that maybe we can do
something different okay so looking at
redesigning the experiences themselves
just sort of the basis of this third
project that I want to talk about which
has similar goals but is also targeting
children rather than adults so this was
before the cocoa movie came out I feel
like now Pixar is gonna yell at me maybe
I don't know but we created an app that
we call Coco's videos
and the intention is to explore how we
can support these same types of
behaviors in preschoolers and there
specifically we were asking can the
technologies that preschoolers are
engaging with support them in learning
to self-regulate their use so can kids
kind of learn these skills early on that
we think are so important to daily life
as they grow there are a lot of
technologies out there that are already
designed to restrict children's use of
technology they are broadly known as
parental controls
they don't teach safe self-regulation
they instead force children to comply
with limits by locking them out of
different experiences so they are
designed to regulate not to support
self-regulation they don't the use of
parental controls doesn't actually
predict children's self-regulation later
so there isn't any evidence that it
supports kids and developing useful
skills and in fact self-determination
theory suggests that imposing these kind
of rigid and controlling structures on
kids would undermine their intrinsic
motivation to self-regulate now in
contrast to parental controls you may
have seen what's known as autoplay or
post play if you've ever watched any
videos online and these aren't you know
explicitly described as mechanisms for
increasing use but there is kind of
they're kind of consistent with that
sort of behavior so they're a common
feature of Internet video on-demand
platforms where when you finish one
video the next one starts playing
automatically you can see this on Hulu
or Netflix or YouTube or even YouTube
kids so it shows up a lot and no one has
looked at how exposure to autoplay or
post play influences self-regulation but
prior findings have said that parents
find it kind of frustrating and think
it's not great for their kids so some of
that
background we set out to explore how we
could design a video player for kids
that would help them in self-regulating
their use and actually taking that step
themselves of turning it off at the end
to do so
we first started with existing
evidence-based curricula for preschool
that teach self-regulation in other
contexts so nothing to do with
technology
the first curriculum that we looked at
is called tools of the mind and one of
the core mechanics here is that it
teaches self-regulation through what's
known as a play plan so it's super cute
it has these four year olds planning out
how they're gonna play and drawing
pictures of what their play is gonna be
like and making these kind of goal
directed choices ahead of time so here's
a play plan by Omari we also looked at
the high scope curriculum which has
about sixty years of really high quality
evidence behind it and has been very
successful at improving kids
self-regulation in ways that persists
throughout their lifetime and this
similarly is built on what's called a
plan do review cycle so lots of elements
here that are similar to the way we
design persuasive technologies for
adults and goal-setting theory and
things like that plan do review has
children kind of plan out in advance
what they're going to do gives them
information as they do it about their
behavior relative to their plan and then
gives them the opportunity to reflect on
what they did and so we took some of
those core mechanics and we created a
bunch of storyboards we did interviews
and diary studies with 55 different
families of preschoolers where we had
them look at some of our design ideas
tell us about daily life keep track of
their transitions at home I spent a lot
of time reading diary entries about kids
tantrums
we did some co.design work with
preschoolers where we had them come in
and help us figure out what this video
player should look like and then we did
a lab session of one of our early
prototypes with 14 families where they
came into the lab and the preschoolers
tried out some of these different
features so we could see how usable they
were for this sometimes challenging
group results of all this was Coco's
videos so they app lets kids plan out
the set of videos that they're going to
watch so it starts by asking them how
much time this experience should take it
then asks them to pick a planned next
activity so what are they going to do
when this experience ends and then they
have a few different mechanisms for
constructing this little playlist where
they can pick from videos that they've
selected in the past they can search for
anything they want on YouTube and they
can select from our recommendations
library to construct this planned
ordered list and you can see it kind of
accumulate over on the left so that's
their plan when they press play the
videos play sequentially as they've
planned and then at the start of the
last video and again one minute before
the full experience ends they see these
little warnings telling them that this
transition is approaching it pauses the
video and they actually have to tap it
to make it go away so they have to
really notice and then at the end that
activity that they had selected as their
next activity is reflected back to them
this cocoa character says to them now
it's time to read are you ready to read
or whatever it is that they had selected
so we created three different versions
of this transition screen at the end
this is our Neutral version where the
only interactive piece is that home
button which lets you go back to the
beginning and select more videos to
watch we created this alternative
version where everything is the same
cocoa comes on and says it's time to
read are you ready to read the home
button is there the child can go back to
the beginning at any time but there's
also this little video player in the
corner that auto plays some more content
related to the last video they just
watched I know evil technology
we created a third version of the
transition screen again everything is
the same as the neutral version except
that there is no home button so you
cannot go back you cannot play more
videos you're just locked into this
experience and it's the brick so these
are our neutral post play and controlled
variants of the experience and
everything else about the experience the
planning and so forth is the theme you
ran a deployment study we recruited 24
families with at least one preschooler
between the ages of 3 & 5 and we asked
them to participate in this three-week
in-home deployment so we gave them a
tablet with our app installed and it
automatically switched between these
three different versions that controlled
neutral and post play versions of our
app for one week each and the order was
turnarounds to cross participants at the
end we had parents complete an exit
survey where they told us a little bit
about their experience and then during
the deployment we collected two
different types of data so first we
logged what kids were doing what they
were watching for how long and when and
then we also collected audio data from
the devices microphone so one minute
before the transition until two minutes
after the transition point we recorded
the ambient audio to give us this really
rich qualitative sample of what was
happening when that kid had to turn off
the device or didn't have to turn off
the device when the experience ended so
to talk about a few of the themes that
came out of this
I haven't even published this yet so
you're the first people to hear about
this so excited um first we saw that
kids really liked talking to cocoa
so cocoa asked this question at the end
based on their next activity like now
it's time to eat are you ready to eat
and kids really wanted to reply they
talked back a lot and they said mm-hmm
I'm hungry or cocoa asks are you ready
to eat the child says yeah I'm going to
get a snack cocoa says it's time to play
outside are you ready to play outside
and the child says I'm ready to play
outside
or of course or sometimes no nope nope
nope nope no I'm so lots of dialogue
with Koko even though Koko is not
interactive and did not respond kids
continue to answer its questions we saw
that our preschoolers displayed a fair
amount of autonomy and ownership over
this transition so they weren't looking
to a parent or asking if it was okay
they were sort of the owner of what
happened next so Coco says it's time to
eat are you ready to eat kids said it's
time to eat and I'm eating or a Coco
says are you ready to eat and the child
set or and mom says what will you do
next clean the living room no child oh
that's not supposed to say it's time to
eat Coco says it's time to play outside
are you ready to play outside
mom says what will you do next clean the
living room the child says no I pick
play outside
obviously Coco says are you ready to
play outside and the child says I'm
ready to go outside I clicked going
outside after my videos I really like
this one super cute Coco says it's time
to do something else are you ready to do
something else a child says now I'm not
going to watch anymore I'm going to do
something else and I'm says okay what
are you going to do a child says now I'm
going to dance put on music I was super
cute they did and they all started
dancing okay so this autonomy that we
saw was interesting because it kind of
showed this goal-directed intentional
behavior and that matters because
engaging in purposeful goal directed
behaviors is the mediating factor
between having opportunities to plan and
seeing gains in self-regulation so they
were super excited to see this show up
we also saw these preschoolers engage in
what's known as other regulation so kind
of regulating the people around them so
Coco says it's time to read are you
ready to read and the kid says dad it's
time to read see what the tablet said or
Koko says it's time for bed and the
child announces
everybody it's time for bed Coco says
it's time to eat are you ready to eat
the child then turns to his brother and
says it's time to eat are you ready to
eat okay so it's time to go somewhere
are you ready to go child tells his
parents like we have to go now first to
mom and then it's dad
and so this other regulation was
interesting because this is kind of a
known developmental step in the process
of internalizing norms and adopting them
for yourself so this is an important
piece of becoming self regulated one
last theme that I wanted to mention was
kids tendency to sort of ritualize these
transitions come to expect them and make
it a part of their routine so Coco says
times bed are you ready to sleep the
child says I want to hear her say it's
time for bed right before that
transition shows up in other instances
we saw kids quoting the Coco transition
audio before it actually played so kind
of anticipating it and doing it for Coco
know what's coming up there's one really
cute one where this little girl
here's Coco say it's time to eat are you
ready to eat and then she says to her
mom mom it's time to eat and mom tells
her like well we care actually eat yet
we have to wait for the rest of the
family to come home and the little girl
says that that's okay but that she wants
to hear Coco say it's time to eat again
when it's actually time to start so all
of these little suggestions that this
kind of parasocial relationship and
little back-and-forth with Coco started
to become somewhat meaningful for kids
and became a routine that they expected
we looked at the differences across
these three different versions of the
app that I mentioned and a few things
showed up fresh we looked up how often
parents had to intervene so actually
come in and take the tablet away or turn
it off for the child
and there were no significant
differences between our neutral and
controlled version although that might
change over a longer time or with a
larger sample but parents were far less
likely to intervene when post play was
up so a lot more fighting and a lot more
kind of not so harmonious engagement
around the tablet we also looked at the
frequency of what we call collaborative
revision so these were instances where
the child did go back and watch more
videos but that was sort of a
collaborative change of plans that the
parent and child agreed on together so
the child says like oh it's done and dad
says well I'm not quite done making
dinner if you want to watch a few more
videos you can and it's okay how long
can I do that for and then goes back to
the beginning and starts again so this
kind of like flexible real time change
of plans
we saw this happened pretty often
actually between 20 and 15 percent of
the time when that was an option
and it almost never happened when they
were locked into the experience at the
end so we kind of precluded this
collaborative revision that seemed to be
something families would engage in when
they had the option when these post play
videos were displayed kids were less
likely to respond to Coco's question
they were less likely to make statements
of autonomy and they spent significantly
longer with the tablet than in either of
the other two conditions and we didn't
see any differences between the neutral
or controlled version along any of these
dimensions as I mentioned we did this
survey at the end where we asked parents
what they liked we asked them if they
liked having this lockout mechanism at
the end and they mostly did what were a
little bit mixed so about a third of the
time parents said they would prefer not
to have that lockout mechanism at all
and kind of on both sides what did they
liked it or didn't they sort of
expressed some appreciation for the
other side as well so parents were sort
of saying well it makes things less
flexible but it makes it a little easier
to transition and kind of appreciating
both
as of that this post play was not very
popular so about a third of parents said
that they didn't really mind it it's
okay if it's there but no one actually
said that this was a feature they wanted
despite the fact that it's in pretty
much every video platform out there and
so a few of the findings that came out
of this first I'm just seeing kids
embracing the planning experience and
then owning this transition so a lot of
autonomy throughout this suggestion that
the transition experience itself and the
kind of UI around that became meaningful
for them the fact that post play was
associated with increased friction
between parents and kids and the fact
that can thus control at the end this
lockout mechanism didn't make much of a
difference in to many of the dimensions
that we looked at so it didn't really
cut down on the amount of time kids
spent with these extra videos it didn't
make a difference in terms of
parent-child friction but it did get in
the way of this collaborative revision
so kind of zooming out a little bit a
few things that have come out of these
and other studies I've done in this
space
first this theme of never or no being
easier than sometimes so if you really
don't want to engage in problematic
behaviors with a particular technology
stop using it altogether that seems to
be the only thing that works well for
people um multiple participants across
these and other studies have told just
use the words Pandora's box when talking
about some of this so parents will say
like just think about whether you even
want to give your kid access because
once you start it's really hard to stop
or adults speaking about their own
behaviors and describing all of these
kinds of patterns of engagement that
come along with their use that they
don't feel great about and so I think
this presents this kind of design
opportunity to rethink some of the
contracts that we're making with our
users and the ways in which they seem to
be a little bit
coercive so we're giving people things
that they value and want to use but it's
not totally on their own terms so I run
the user empowerment lab at the
University of Washington and our kind of
overarching mission is to redesign our
everyday technologies so that we are
given users the value that they want
without coercing them into accepting
side-effects that they don't really want
so hopefully it's clear how that shows
up in this project I'm just going to
really briefly mention four projects
that we've started recently I'm that
fall under this umbrella first we know
that on Android devices apps are way
over permissions so users allow make
decisions about security permissions at
install time and there isn't really any
granularity after that so it was super
easy for me to have Coco's videos just
listen in on people's conversations and
then upload that to the cloud and then
listen to it and like of course there's
lots of IRB oversight and I had lots of
conversations with my participants about
that but you know every app that you're
using might not be so thoughtful so what
can we do that allows users to give apps
the power that they need when it offers
value to the user without kind of
opening this Pandora's box of potential
exploitation so how can you allow an app
to support voice search without letting
it listen to everything you do at all
times one project that we're working on
now considers the fact that victims of
intimate partner violence have
systematic ways in which they will
leverage social media and mobile devices
to escape abusive situations but other
work has shown that those exact same
technologies are things that abusers
used to track stalk harass their victims
and separate them from other social
relations so how can we support this
vulnerable population in getting access
to all of those tools that can help and
empower them without also exposing them
to this added risk
another project we're working on and
it's about understanding the biases that
occur or the way that our interactions
with voice interfaces shape our biases
and so as this technology becomes kind
of mainstream what are the potentially
unanticipated side effects that come
along with that and what should we do
about it as designers and then finally
we're working on this project to look at
civil discourse in online spaces so is
it possible to be part of Reddit but
without having to accept all the trolls
that go along with it so for different
things that I'm excited about um that
all seem a little bit daunting but when
all of the undergrads here apply to my
PhD programs we will be able to solve
all of these big challenges I was I just
when I gave a shout out to my awesome
students who have helped in so many ways
with so much of this and also to all of
the people who have helped with these
user user engagement projects it totally
takes a village to give a Stanford talk
so grateful to all of them and to all of
you for being here thanks so much
[Applause]
[Music]
when you you mean in the survey at the
beginning where we were asking people
what they wanted to try long term yeah
yeah I think that matters a lot we I
would say we looked at that a little but
not as deeply as might be useful so for
example we asked all of our deployment
participants name if you could change
one thing about the way you use your
phone
describe what that would be so that we
had some context around what they were
interested in doing and then we looked
at different features of those interests
so for example we saw that some people
were very reduction focused we called it
where they really wanted to cut back on
something other people were very context
focused where they didn't necessarily
want to use their phone less but they
wanted to make these more targeted
context specific changes we saw people
who wanted to keep using their phone but
kind of displace certain behaviors with
others so I want to make more voice
calls relative and fewer texts that kind
of thing we didn't look kind of at we
didn't have people describe whether they
felt like they were addicted there's
some work that has shown that people
generally experience this more as
annoyance than addiction so
understanding that I think would be
really useful oh yeah a little bit and I
think it's a super important
what's been your biggest frustration
working on this progress or designing
with two-year-olds horrible no I'm
joking it's like a question so I think
one thing that's frustrating is the
point that James made before of just the
incentive structure and the kind of
larger system around all of this that
sometimes just feels oppressive it's
like what if I figure out exactly what's
going on here like then what like so
what it doesn't matter because so many
people make so much money off of this so
that feels like an uphill battle some
days although as I was saying I think
less so I think behavior change type
projects are hard in general and there
have definitely been moments of like
okay I want to teach kids
self-regulation and then I just feel
like that's just an impossible task so a
lot of these have felt like I don't even
know where to start
one thing that I've done a lot to try to
get around that is to look at what has
happened in other domains that's been
successful and try to build from there
because if all I have to do is translate
somebody else's work into an app that is
much easier than if I have to figure out
everything from scratch and then finally
one last thing I would mention is some
resistance to design from people so this
might just this might be more true in
the u.s. than other places but people
have this really strong kind of sense of
self-reliance and desire for self
control so I remember like presenting
one interviewee with different design
ideas what do you think about this or
that or like these are for a weak minded
people with no self-control and I think
that's kind of a common sentiment like
we think it's all on us which is
interesting given that people are really
working hard to kind of break down our
self-control and hold our attention for
as long as possible
so there's an interesting tension there
where I want to like respect what users
want and users think that they want
their own self-control to be kind of the
sum all of what happens but meanwhile
they're kind of fighting in a
battle so that resistance to design just
kind of like undermines my whole
research agenda dig into this economic
argument a little bit because a it it
rings a little hollow to me in the
following way like if we take other
domains in which there is an economic
incentive to increase consumption yeah
as an example or well I suppose think
that way
there are also there are entire
companies and industries that having
economic incentives about trying to help
people reduce them think about like sort
of the exercise and diet industries and
others they're like there's you can
argue that each individual player only
has say the economic incentive to
increase consumption or something like
that but there is a counterbalance in a
way that I feel like I actually don't
really see so much within the tech
industry I don't see it in just like an
industry that's me that people are
paying money to do the equivalent of
like exercise more or have more
self-control or spending less time
wondering if it would be possible to yes
we should you know Facebook Google etc
should definitely be considering how to
improve their you know their designs and
make them less addictive in various ways
their ways to actually sort of throw
that kind of counterculture incentive in
a way that we see in many other domains
yeah yeah I mean I don't know if this is
still true but I saw some statistic a
couple years ago about how America
spends more money than any other country
on healthcare and the least amount of
money on food or something like that and
it seems similar where there's like this
I don't know these two players in this
arms race for your your health so I
don't know I've seen a lot of resistance
to these outside tools there are a
number of commitment devices that you
can buy to help you cut back on your use
I'm not sure that they're well-designed
enough so maybe that's the problem but
there also seems to be some user
resistance
adopting them people want to think it's
on them that they can do it themselves
without help not sure exactly why that's
a little different from the diet
metaphor where people are perfectly
willing to go have a personal trainer
help them or have you know a calorie
counting buddy or something like that
whose fault it is if I'm eating foods
yeah I mean that actually to speak to
the frustration question the kind of
social ideologies about tech addiction
and what's good use and what's bad use
and distraction and your alidade if you
don't use this stuff but you're an
addict if you do use this stuff that
definitely complicates all of this in
terms of what users want and think they
want and how we respond to that and even
as a researcher how I think about some
of these questions like when am I just
kind of imposing value judgments about
tech use being bad and when is there
actually something negative for people
happening and our kind of thing videos
I'm surprised by like the lack of user
outrage when you like took away their
ability to like you just like stopped
them in like the middle of a of a video
so the time limit is a cap and you can
only add videos to the playlist in whole
units up to that higher bound cartoons
only - yeah you can watch wheels on the
bus for like 300 minutes or something
like that yeah totally
so it would start by bringing up search
results that fit in their total cap and
then as their budget shrinks they kind
of disappear or grayed out and that
works because kids don't understand time
very well YouTube videos like a strange
does hellscape yeah
what are some ways that they can avoid
kind of like falling into design
patterns that are kind of bad for these
days yeah that's a good question so I
think the first thing to do is to not
explicitly try to do it on purpose so
there's a whole field around what's
known as dark patterns I don't know what
that something you heard of but you can
look for these kind of known ways of
sneaking extra stuff into people's
shopping carts like oh look you should
buy this travel insurance you totally
need that I know you do or telling
people that they can like use this
coupon code but not applying it for them
automatically and then making it kind of
hard to find later so there are all of
these dark patterns where you can kind
of intentionally decide to do things
that are manipulative or addictive or
keep people there longer so the first
thing I would say is don't do it on
purpose and then the second part is
harder figuring out what we can kind of
proactively do this kind of idea of a
contained amount of content I think is
helpful and having people decide for
themselves the sort of serving size of
what they want to consume I think aligns
with a lot of best practices around
intentionality and mindfulness and kind
of respecting users once so instead of
having kind of like an endless stream of
content that they can continue to
consume having them define how much
content there is helps in these project
and one other that I didn't talk about
today Koko's videos and past design
project we saw that having intentional
stopping points or kind of natural
stopping points I guess is a better way
to say it was helpful so kids don't
actually have to stop at the end it's
just kind of like a natural place to
pause to give them that moment of
self-reflection so kind of like chapters
in a book or something like that the
book isn't over you can keep going but
there's sort of this natural nudge to
stop and think and say like do I really
want to keep going as opposed to just
kind of being drawn in through inertia I
think that helps
you study right now where it seems like
the thing that gets people to stop is to
show them the same content again so I
don't know exactly what to make of that
yet I don't think I would recommend
doing that intentionally as a design
feature but I think exploring that will
be interesting familiar with Stan Harris
time well spent and I'm certainly
sending for humane technology I'm
wondering if you have any thoughts about
the way that we track things like this
that we find that are interested in
tends to be unfair things that we're
trying to reduce our our time with so if
I save them in Facebook or on Twitter or
something they're more likely to go back
there and say what do you have so I'm
sorry you're saying like you
intentionally go back to these
experiences because that's where you're
tending to track the things that your
shouldn't follow it even if it's
technology use protection
like bookmark bucket where you can move
things that you have decided
intentionally that you're interested in
to some kind of sandbox and then you can
go check up on that doing and I mean I
think the Center for Humane technology
was only announced like a couple weeks
ago or something um recently a couple
investors at Apple wrote this open
letter to the company so they owned
about a billion dollars worth of shares
and they wrote this letter saying like
you're addicting our kids this is so bad
for them you have to stop it so it's an
exciting time to be alive if your
parental controls researcher like this
is great and so a year ago there was a
lot less traction around some of these
questions so it's exciting to see the
change change an attitude
what was the satisfaction for like me
and you like the children on the group
of videos with like that experience this
is just like the unrestricted
automatically always playing the sorts
of things that's a good question so we
asked them about how much the kid liked
the app in general but we didn't survey
the kids at the end and we didn't ask
them we asked the parents which features
they like I was kind of worried that we
wouldn't get like high fidelity
responses if we were trying to get like
feature by feature feedback from
three-year-olds so we didn't do that
but in general I mean the kids loved it
but the bar is pretty low I mean they're
preschoolers in its videos so yeah we
were sort of setting ourselves up for
success yeah we mentioned children's
black of comprehension of the time all
right
and I wonder to what extent kids
understand that they're self-regulating
when they're setting a time limit at the
beginning they don't actually know it 20
minutes yeah so with the time limit
piece I don't think is I don't think
that's like a super meaningful activity
for the kids in this age range by the
older end a little bit but that was
mostly like a pragmatic constraint and
we expected that piece to be negotiated
with a parent and we really just wanted
to I think first of all if we were using
content that were in a more standardized
format that would be easier for kids to
understand so by this age kids can
understand the idea of two episodes
versus three 18 minutes is not really
meaningful yet and so I don't think that
that is playing an important role I
think that choosing what they're going
to do next
being in charge of what the content is
and kind of seeing the holistic
experience going through that and then
stopping are the kind of pieces that
contribute to self-regulation I doubt
that setting the timer if they're
negotiating with a parent ahead of time
how much time they have yeah how is that
different from a parent saying at the
end you've reached your time limit go do
something else
your child in picking a new activity
yeah so I think that one thing that's
really important is that this kind of
scaffolds this point of self-regulation
so it leads them up to it and then gives
them the freedom to choose to
self-regulate and to like take that hard
step of turning it off or not
so if parent comes in and says oh time's
up you're done then the kid isn't really
doing the act of self-regulation in the
same way and they can you know like
certainly parents and kids can can make
that happen but we kind of standardized
it a little so that was always sort of
the experience we'll take any other
questions offline let's thank our
speaker one more time
you